thank you good afternoon everyone and
welcome to a meeting of council for the
7th of march
item 1 apologies for absence i have
apologies from councillors
reader
angelique and mark foster
council parking council
council hearts on
and councillors drabble
dayton
and lewis are there any other apologies
if not we move to item two declarations
of interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest in items on
the agenda and withdraw from the meeting
at the appropriate time
i'd like to declare that as a member of
the written board
item 14 where i'll be leaving the
meeting council off
i have the same declare interest in that
item
council liggette
uh i won't without voting on item seven
thank you counter clock
item 14 chair
thank you and council welton uh same
thanks thank you any other declarations
we've got item three minutes the last
meeting to approve as a correct record
the minutes that have been circulated do
we have a proposal please thank you
council dale and the second it counselor
cupid
all those in favor
thank you anyone against
any abstentions
not they have been approved thank you
so item 4 cham's announcements
i'm sure colleagues will be horrified by
recent events in ukraine
there is significant emotional impact of
seeing daily accounts of the war
and it is impossible
not to be moved by the devastating
images on our screens
it is difficult to comprehend how lives
have been changed forever
by bullets and bombs
to hear the needless deaths of so many
civilians
the developing refugee crisis
and appalling siege tactics
that has turned us all into hostages of
putin's imperialism
we are all bystanders in putin's war
where we are left observing human
suffering
on our own european doorstep in the 21st
century
the archbishop of canterbury sum things
up for me
when he said
what is happening in ukraine
burns a hole
in your soul
there are humanitarian efforts going on
to make a difference
some of those are happening now in our
own district
i commend john curry and his son peter
as well as the cary grand four paul's
hotel
who are collecting items and driving
across to deliver them
each and every one can play our part
including donating to the disasters
emergency committee
as a council
we are flying the ukrainian flag here at
mill lane
to demonstrate our solidarity
with the people of ukraine
officers have contacted fund managers
to determine any links to russian and
belarusian assets in our portfolios
to date no direct exposure to russian or
belarusian assets has been identified
we will ensure continual review of this
for all the families of ukrainian
children i have taught in northeast
derbyshire
those ukrainian colleagues i have had
the privilege of working with
and for all those impacted in any way
my message is simple
slav ukrainia
partnership in europe has taken on
renewed significance
on the 17th of february senior officers
and myself participated in a virtual
meeting with the land rat and staff from
darmstadt dieberg to discuss climate
change
this is the beginning of a reimagined
way of promoting close ties between our
communities
several approaches to promoting greener
thinking were shared along with
encouragement for all we are doing to
tackle the climate emergency
the day following the meeting was a race
night in aid of my appeal freshgate
hospice
and i'm grateful to councillor jane
barry for organizing a great evening
that raised 1 000 pounds
thank you
we will not describe your behavior that
night councilor barker
but i am appreciative of those who have
supported the event especially
councillor hartsawn for his generosity
april has a few events you may wish to
attend including a spring fair at the
technique stadium on the 30th of april
st george's day concert at chatsworth on
the 23rd
and a peaky blinders night at the casa
hotel on the 16th of april
featured our vehicles used in the
filming of the television series
and dancing to cals cats
it's going to be a special evening
in april councillor shipman has kindly
agreed to have his hair shaved by me
following full council
please sponsor councillor shipman but be
reassured i won't be combining peaky
blinders with my shaving technique on
that occasion
thank you all for your ongoing support
item five leaders announcements please
thank you chair um firstly just to echo
and associate myself with the very
powerful words you made around ukraine
as a council we are uh we've already
been very clear with our partner
councils and with the government that we
wish to help in any way we can and
obviously as details emerge we will we
will discuss that and bring that to the
attention of all members um but
absolutely echo what you're saying
around encouraging residents to to
continue to do the amazing things that
they are all doing um by supporting the
the people of ukraine um in terms of
covid obviously i think most of us will
welcome the complete removal of the
restrictions um although we do continue
to advise residents to remain cautious
and be sensible and do all the things
that most of us have now gotten used to
like hand washing and uh and mass in in
enclosed spaces and those sorts of
things
we are still making good progress with
uh our agile working changes and and the
key priority at the moment is around
ensuring that our premises namely this
building
is fit for purpose in terms of meeting
the demands of the new ways of working
so there is a lot of work and progress
being made on that
um in terms of cabinet i think you'll
see in the pack of information there's
been some slight changes to
portfolios um councillor kenyon will now
cover
economic development in addition to
climate and transformation uh council
running will now cover housing and
community safety and councillor powell
will cover uh leisure in addition to
communities
and communications and i'd just like to
thank them all for all the work they
have done in their in their previous
portfolios and obviously look forward to
working with them
in their in their newer roles
you'll hopefully have seen the news
around county deals in that derbyshire
and derby
have been shortlisted
for a county deal which could bring new
powers and funding to the area it's
still very early days and i would stress
that
there is a lot to be worked up with
government in terms of the exact shape
of the deal the government have been
very clear that these deals are between
the government and the upper tier
authorities
although the davis county council have
been very clear that they do want the
deal to work on a collaborative basis
with the districts and boroughs very
firmly at the table
there will be two um q a briefing
sessions for all members this is all
city county district and borough
councillors to attend later this month
so we will
advertise the the details of those
sessions and hopefully you know as many
of you who are interested in finding out
more about the county deal and the shape
that it may take we'll be able to go
along
and find out more
um a few quick items from uh from recent
cabinet meetings i'm very pleased to
announce that we received a 1.4 million
pound public sector decarbonisation
grant for drumfield ledger center uh
which will follow enable it to follow in
eckington's footsteps we very recently
reviewed the fly tipping enforcement
and having benchmarked with
other
neighboring local authorities we've
taken the decision to increase
our
penalties
to the maximum for fly tipping and
littering and this will hopefully help
to ensure that local residents know that
we're taking a zero tolerance stance
on this scourge of an issue within our
beautiful countryside
um we're also deploying more technology
and the use of trialling the use of
remote cctv as well in known flight
tipping hotspots so
we are doing a lot of work around that
at the moment
i'd like to thank our homelessness team
um at the council for their fantastic
work in helping to prevent
75 families from becoming homeless over
the winter
following a grant from the government's
household support fund
uh and i can't help but uh but highlight
um
despite some of the veiled criticism of
the last meeting uh the fact that we've
approved our parking strategy um which
will uh which will be committing to 280
000 pounds per year to dealing with some
of the most challenging parking hotspots
in the district and finding pragmatic
solutions in a way that the council has
not done before so very pleased about
that and i think that covers it thank
you very much
chair thank you council dale so item six
public participation well no questions
have been submitted under procedure rule
number eight so we move to item seven
which are outcomes of the review of the
chair of licensing allowance by the
independent remuneration panel so i'm
going to head over to the monitoring
officer
thank you chair the report as as said is
in the supplementary pack
further to previous reports to members
on the establishment of the irp we have
now been able to appoint three members
as required by law the panel has now met
to consider whether the role of chair of
licensing should receive an sra a
special responsibility allowance related
to that role as part of the members
allowances scheme
currently this chair receives no sra
the information considered by the panel
is detailed in the report and this
includes that no other council in
derbyshire does not give an sra to the
chair of licensing
in simpler words we're the only
authority in derbyshire that doesn't
give an sra for the chairman of
licensing
having considered the matter the panel's
recommendation is that an sra should be
paid and it should be paid at the same
rate as a chair of standards
if a vice chair were appointed there
should be an sra at the same rate as the
vice chair of standards
the recommendations are on page three of
the supplementary pack now that you
consider the recommendations of the irp
in relation to the role of chair and
vice chair of licensing agree a suitable
remuneration for such decisions if
appropriate
and if you do agree an sra consider
whether to backdate it in accordance
with the legislation quoted in the
recommendation
just remembers information there will be
a few full review of the members
allowances scheme that's commencing you
later this month thank you chair
any comments or questions for the
monitoring officer
if not then can we move the
recommendations so counselor dale
thank you chair just to say i i strongly
support the recommendations within the
paper and i do believe that we should
back date to the earliest possible day i
think it's worth highlighting that
council liggett
has fulfilled this role since may uh
2020 um so it is disappointing that it
can't be backdated to then but actually
as i understand it local government
regulations require that it can only be
to the beginning of the financial year
but as
as mrs sternberg has said um no other
council does this i think it's a it's a
bit of a hard back to when the
cabinet member used to fulfill this role
and obviously that's not how we're doing
things at the moment so i think it is
right and proper that um that the amount
of work that goes into to doing that
role is is rightly um recompense so yeah
fully support the recommendations happy
to move them and i move that we do back
date to the beginning of the financial
year thank you thank you do we have a
second up
thank you council cupid
are there any comments or questions
it's not been moved and seconded all
those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
one and that's carried
thank you
item eight the northeast arms district
council annual pay policy statement so
hand over to councillor dale
thank you chair this is a report that we
bring every year as a procedural matter
we're
required to to report on this um it's
for awareness and consideration really
the pay policy statement sets out our
policy on pay for senior managers and
all employees
the reporting statement reflects the
current position uh based on the
decisions we've made
previously at full council and we have
an obligation under the local government
transparency code to publish the
information
relating to pay and structures including
functional responsibilities budget and
staff resources annually on websites
and obviously the the statement itself
is included in the appendix
i don't think there's much more
to say really than that so i'm happy to
move the recommendations that we that we
accepted thank you do we have a second
thank you council cupid any comments or
questions
okay we'll move to the vote then all
those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
and that is carried thank you item nine
level of council tax for 2022-23
council parking is absent through
illness so i'm going to hand over to
counselor dale
yeah thank you chair um again this is a
fairly procedural paper the the localism
act 2011
requires us as the billing authority to
calculate the council tax requirements
each year
and each preceptor obviously approves
their demand when setting their annual
budget as we did on the 31st of january
and since then obviously
all the
parish councils the county the fire
authority the police commissioner et
cetera have all made their decisions
so we obviously have to take all of
those those other um precepting
authorities into account
the table on paragraph 2.5 sets out the
levels of council tax
for the year accumulating all of the
preceptors demands
and i don't think there's much more to
say other than to to move the
recommendation
thank you do you have a secondary
council cupid thank you any comments or
questions councillor barker
thank you chair can you hear that i know
this is procedural and i know that that
we uh
because we're the collection authority
we have to agree these figures in front
of us but i just feel i hope to make a
point that really all these other
authorities
uh are putting up
precepts quite significantly including
themselves
uh and it should be noted that quite a
few councils in this room a party to
those decisions so and it don't seem
that long ago that the the same
counselors were in a photo i remember
holding up a big plaque saying they
weren't going to put council tax up and
i'm just saying
that i might remind you of that in about
12 months time
cheers
thank you any other comments or
questions
council shipman
thank you chair um
we obviously need to keep putting cancer
tax up slightly because we're getting
cuts from central government i think
that's what this boils down to
um this council is underfunded it's
financially
um
you know if you look at the uh
it's not
sorry um
and and yeah we had a report uh last
month or the month before coming to full
council where you know the finances are
fine this year but if you look into the
future
it's not looking fine and i think that
that needs to be made clear that we're
having to put it up because we've been
made to put it up
but i think the leadership of this
council need to be lobbying government
for more money because we simply can't
go on as we are doing
and i think that that needs to be
addressed sooner rather than later
before this council is on its knees
any other comments or questions
counselor dale to reply
thanks uh thanks chad i think the photo
that councillor barker has referring to
i think dates back to 2013 but um
i think it's different times obviously
you know i'm a conservative if i could
freeze council tax i would do it every
year but blatantly obviously at the
moment we can't inflation the rate it is
at the moment um you know i think it's
necessary to to make increases but not
all other authorities have increased by
the maximum obviously dcc could have
increased by five percent and chose to
increase by three
um you know we've taken the decision to
increase by two point five eight percent
i still think it's uh modest on the
basis of of um you know the inflation
that we're susceptible to as well as an
organization
um i think cancer shipments point um you
know times are are hard and we we are um
having to make the decisions to to stay
viable as an organization but i don't
think actually the budget position is as
bad as you are uh you're suggesting i
feel quite comfortable that we will
transform as an organisation and we need
to all
no organization can stand still
we need to transform and i think that we
will do it i don't think necessarily
that uh throwing more money at the
situation is always the answer and we
have actually avoided uh making any
major cuts to any frontline services or
any major redundancies and i don't think
that's necessarily on the cards in the
future either so we are doing well and i
think the budget situation is
is actually
not as bad as you're making out
thank you well uh according to
procedures we this is
requiring a recorded vote so i'm going
to hand over to the monitoring officer
please
thank you chair i'll reach each read
each of your names and ask you to say
whether you're voting for against or
abstaining and as we have been doing in
recent past i will start at the end of
the alphabet
councillor p wright
four
councillor b wright
again
councillor winley
abstain
councillor wheelhouse
council welton
for councillor thacker paul
council
tate council stone
councillor stratford stevenson
councillor shipman
four
councillor rough four
councillor rouse
four
council row
four council ridgeway
councillor powell
councillor potts
four
council plats
four
councillor pickering for councillor
morley
councillor lilly
for
councillor liggett for
councillor lacey
councillor kerry
councillor kenyon for
councillor jones
councillor hutchinson
councillor holmes
council hancock
elliott
councillor dale four council cupid full
council cornwall
four council cooper
council club
four council birkin
council barry
four
council barca
or cancer armitage for
councillor adlife
the results are 39 full
two against and one abstention so that's
carried
thank you so item 10 to answer any
questions from members asked under
procedure rule 9.2 the first one is a
question from council fernell to the
leader
will you council for now
before i ask the question can i just
endorse the comments and statements
that's been made about ukraine and a big
thank you to
the residents across northeast
derbyshire who are all doing their
little bit to try and help the situation
so the question i have for for the
leader
is can the leader confirm that all
section 106
contributions
generated following new builds
will be used 100 percent
for the benefit of the community which
is being affected
by the new builds in their area
council dale to reply thank you
councillor fernell for the uh for the
question the starting point for any
section 106 agreement is that it must be
necessary to make the development
acceptable in planning terms directly
related to the development and fairly
and reasonably related in scale and kind
to the development
as a result any community infrastructure
proposal to be funded by section 106
money is very likely to be within or
very close to the settlement in which
the development is located
this somewhat depends though on how the
section 106 agreement is worded and how
specific it is in terms of its scope
each agreement will either state a
specific project that the money goes uh
towards uh for example a new classroom
at st peter's primary school or the
refurbishment of
the multi-use games area at central park
for example
or the general purpose of the money i.e
improved education facilities within the
catchment area of x application sites or
improved access or equipment to
or enlargement of public open space
within x kilometers of the application
site but even when that wording is less
specific it's worth remembering that
section 106 is often required
to make a development sustainable and
it's in the best interest of the
developer as well as well that the
monies are spent as locally as possible
it often makes their developments more
saleable
as well so developers of course have the
right
to challenge section 106 spending where
they feel it's not within keeping
with the written agreements so the
summary is section 106 money can only be
spent in accordance with what is
specified in the agreement wording and i
hope that's a useful answer
answer for now do you have a
supplementary question
no not for this day thank you
thank you so we moved to the next
question which is uh from council
shipment to council parking you've got a
slight problem
um but if you want to ask your question
um and then i'll allow council dale to
respond in councillor parking's absence
with what would happen next
counselorship thank you chair um at the
last council meeting members were told
that social hours and rents
would increase by 4.1 percent in line
and i'm quoting there with government
guidance however upon further
investigation it was found to be a cap a
maximum cap by the government not a
recommendation can
uh councillor dale
clarify this inconsistency please
can answer the dale
thank you chair i think we're going to
uh provide a written reply uh in
response to this i don't think it's fair
that i clarify remarks made by someone
else so
if you'll forgive us we'll we'll send a
written reply um on for council park and
we'll send one when he's back fitting
back to work
so that's what's going to happen council
shipments so when you get a written
response you are entitled to ask a
supplementary to that written response
and then a written response will come to
that and then we'll collect all of that
and put those into the minutes so there
will be transparency about the response
that you've had in the supplementary and
any other further response to that as
well
so so can some other counselors will be
able to see oh yeah what the response is
yes
okay so we'll move to item 11 to
consider any motions from members under
procedure rule number 10
so we have a motion submitted by council
shipment over to you please
thank you chair um
obviously
i hope
everyone across this chamber would
abdullah
racism in all its forms
we've obviously had a recent situation
where
a drum filled town counsellor
before before we proceed can we make
sure we don't get into individual
circumstances i don't think that's going
to be
relevant to a debate that we're having
here at the district so please don't
mention any individual cases
the the names publicly
aren't the public so we're okay talking
about it we're not
and that case has already been dealt
with it's been adjudicated on and it
would be inappropriate to discuss it or
even
you see this is where there is a problem
because it's not been dealt with
it's been looked in it's been looked at
but that doesn't necessarily mean it's
been dealt with
um but i think the point needs making
that there's recent situations where the
code of conduct's not been able to be
applied because
said councillors
allegedly are doing this in their
private life
whereas the way i look at it is that we
all have a do when we're elected we all
have a duty to represent our areas now
it doesn't matter if i'm if i'm if i
were to make racist comments at the pub
no one's going to be able to know the
difference between ross as a counselor
or ross saying it as an individual
in his private life and i think that
that we need to actually get this
clarified because the code of conduct
does need to apply
to all of us whatever we are doing if we
are saying stuff in a public forum and
that's the key here if we're saying
stuff in the public forum then the code
of conduct should be able to investigate
that situation and come up with a
recommendation
in response to that and i think that
what we've found recently is that that's
not been able to happen and through no
fault of anyone in this council that is
just the system that we are having to
operate uh within um and i hope that
everyone in this council chamber would
support this motion because quite
clearly
um we can't have
a repeat
of the situation we have had where
potential racist comments have not been
able to be investigated by the
monitoring office by the monitoring
officer of this council thank you chair
thank you do you have a second uh
get out of hancock
thank you chair i'm happy to second i'll
i'll reserve my right to speak until
later please thank you
so um
any comments on
the motion that's been put forward
counselor dale
thank you chef um clearly our our group
fully super supports the
first bit of the motion around racism
but actually we feel um it should be
amended to cover all forms of
discrimination i think if we left it as
it were it would i think our residents
would feel that it fell short
you know in terms of the wider
discrimination that people face so we
are going to propose a slight amendment
and i'll cover that in a moment i think
with regard to the scope of the con code
of conduct i think it's fair to say that
our group on the whole takes a bit more
of a balanced approach we do recognize
that high standards we recognize the
high standards that our residents expect
of us
as councillors
but we also all should be also should be
entitled to a private life and i'm not
suggesting that that's in any in any way
related to the case that you're
suggesting but in other forms uh you
know in other ways we all have a private
life and we have to just
carefully strike that balance between
allowing us all to have a private life
and also suitably applying the code of
conduct um you know in the ways that our
residents would expect
um so i think if we if we were to um
i think if we were to to take that to
its natural course we'd like to propose
uh some amendments to the motion so i'll
read out a slightly amended version of
the motion if that's okay
the council aborts discrimination in all
its forms and in all circumstances
council accepts that the public do not
always understand that the code of
conduct does not apply to the behaviour
of a counselor in their private life
council believes that members are
entitled to a private life and therefore
accepts that the code of conduct only
applies to members while they are
conducting their role as council
councillors
but council agrees that the chair of
standards committee should write to the
secretary of state asking whether the
applicability of the code of conduct
should be extended to apply to a
councillor's private life
in addition to their role as a
councillor in those cases where there is
a direct impact on the reputation of
this council
that's the proposed amendment chair
do we have a second day for that
okay council cupid thank you
you're reserving your right to uh thank
you right so we're
we're on the amendment
do you accept the amendment does it yes
yes i mean it's basically what it says
so the amendment is accepted so um
we can take this as this
substantive um motion so um
let us debate the substantive motion
which is the one that's just been
amended a counselor marker
he put me on spot there alex i wasn't
expecting that
gonna have a minute to read it now
if they accept it uh i think i mean my
speech obviously about that you know
that we accept the sentiments in the
motion and i know it's a tricky one and
you put a sentence in there about having
a private life
but
i think we all accept that
whether we wherever we are people know
us as counsellors and and that can all
then reflect badly on the council
whichever one it is that you sit on so
it is a a very thin line between private
and when you're a council when you're
not and unfortunately
and uh
it is
as
as
you'll verify from friday night
that there's sometimes it's it is a grey
area but
we i think if if the lib dems accept
that amendment
where our group is as well
any other comments or questions
council really
yeah i mean i don't know what what
whatever whatever could your politics
are or whatever else we have all
we have all
got a law to face
and there are laws of this land that
discover discrimination that they cover
the core racism and each and every
individual whether it be a councillor or
maybe a private person should be held
accountable to that to the full strength
of the law i will support this
and i hope everybody else will do the
same with the same sentiments
thank you council barry
chair for me the the discrimination you
know like jeff's just said that there's
a law of the law that goes with that
my concerns are i feel that this is
i'm happy to accept this but i feel as
if we when we have staff
that break the court of conduct
they're disciplined
and actions taken against them whether
it's in their personal life or not
what's the difference between that and a
counsellor
you know they they would bring somebody
into disrepute and we would do something
about that so there's no difference
between a member of staff
doing this
and a counsellor doing it and you've not
acted strongly enough as far as i'm
concerned in it i will back this if if
the lib dems do but you need to do
something about what you've not done and
sort it out sooner rather than later
any other comments or questions
council pickering
thank you chair yeah yeah i mean i think
it's um
quite an important uh motion and um
i think uh the amendment that's been put
forward to extend it to all forms of
oppression
um is is extremely useful rather than
single something out
uh
i would just hope that the private life
part of it
isn't some kind of loophole that can be
used in the future
and
what we should be thinking about if
people say something in their own home
behind closed doors
um that's out of earshot of the general
public that might be private life
if somebody's not acting as a counselor
but does something in public
and we know that things have been put on
twitter and other social media
that actually might be private comments
but they're out in the public domain
that's what we should be concentrating
on
i'm not too bothered about what people
do behind their own closed doors that's
private it's what's accessible to the
public
and we should make that clear because
otherwise
i understand what uh counsellor dale is
trying to say but it's a bit weak unless
we tighten that up a bit
casa ridgeway
yes i totally agree with what councillor
pickering said i mean yes we're entitled
to a private life that's behind closed
doors and out of the public domain but
facebook and twitter
whether you're in your home or whatever
in the car is not your private life that
is
giving it out to the public so i think
if we are going to go with this we need
to make sure that it does state that as
a counselor you do not voice your
anti-dis you know discriminatory ideas
or philosophy
on anything that is in the public domain
such as facebook and things like that
i'm going to come back i know when you
accepted the amendment so yours was then
became the
the secondary party but if you want to
go i'm going to come back to council
hancock for a comment if you wish to and
then we're going to come back to you
counselorship
thank you chair and uh thank you for
everyone who has spoken i mean council
pickering sums up perfectly the intent
behind the motion um i mean obviously
in this room we've got very different
political views but i think we all sing
from the same hymn sheet when we we all
oppose discrimination in all of its
forms
um none of it is ever acceptable and one
of the big problems that we have is one
bad apple
casts castings on all of us and one
person's behavior of this nature
reflects badly on all of us no matter
how well intentions and how our own
personal motives
it's good to hear so many positive
positive comments towards it um and
hopefully this is going to pass um
unanimously thank you chair thank you
encounter shipment
yeah i think i think it's been
summarized well by everyone that's
spoken actually that that
you know
there's a difference between private
life behind closed doors and what you're
up to in your private life but posting
stuff on let's say twitter in an open
forum when you can actually restrict
your posts as well
that to me is a in a public forum and
therefore as far as i'm concerned you're
acting as a counselor because you're
making your comments um known to the
general public and i'd like to think
that
this counsellor would be condemned
locally
by
other people in this room
and actually constrain again
counselorship well well i mean to be
fair though if somebody might if if
someone in my group was doing behavior
like that
they would be sung out of this group my
group
can we just stick to the street
and well we can talk about it in the
district format if one if myself david
or pam was to come out with comments
that i've seen personally on twitter
they would be sung out my group and i
expect every other group in this room
would act in a similar manner whether
that's at paris district county or any
in any other form where we are all
grouped up
and i'd like to see actual action from
individuals rather than this be
just you know we're right to the
secretary of state and that's the last
we hear of it
thank you council dale to reply
just in response to councillor pickering
and council ridgway's points i think
that's that's exactly the point i think
we're trying to make with the final uh
in addition to their roles against where
there is a direct impact on the
reputation of council that's what we
really mean by that private life thing
and that's that's the balance we're
trying to strike so i think i think we
do absolutely agree with what you're
saying and that that's the that's the
intention that's it thank you so we come
to the motion as amended um so all those
in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
so that's unanimous that's good news
thank you
so item 12
um i move that the public be excluded
from the meeting during the discussion
of the following item of business to
avoid the disclosure to them of exempt
information as defined in paragraphs one
and three part one of schedule 12 a to
the local government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
have a secondary second thank you
council rule for those in favor
[Music]
anyone against
any abstentions
that's carried we're now moving to
excluded parts so we need to stop the
live feed
item 15 as an urgent business we we have
a the report
linked to uh
chairing uh one of the screw to the
committee so we'll hand over to council
dale please
thank you chair unfortunately uh
councillor hutchinson due to work
commitments to stand down from his role
as chair of uh growth scrutiny and i'd
like to thank him for
all of his time and and effort um you
know in previous years into that role um
i'd like to propose that we nominate
councillor stratford-stevenson uh to
replace him obviously for the remainder
of the uh the civic year
um i think that's it thank you
do we have a second
thank you council cupid any other
nominations
no no comment
if it been for the price is right i i
would have uh
uh yeah that though you'll want to know
what he did at race night soon i can
tell you
all those then in favor of the of
council stratford stevenson
anyone against
any abstentions
that's it congratulations council
stratfor siemens and you are elected
thank you
there is no other urgent business from
myself so can i thank you all for your
attendance and declare the meeting
closed
you